this program is being presented to you
by the Harris international winter
school on gravity and lights welcome
back to the second tutorial of their w/e
Korea's international winter school on
gravity and lunge now we will deal with
topological manifolds the first exercise
is again a multiple-choice exercise with
three questions again we shall take the
correct ones and but not the incorrect
ones so part a topological manifolds of
course have integer dimension this is
correct
topological manifolds are equipped with
a topology and exactly one shot no that
is not correct
topological manifolds are equipped with
a topology of course but they can be
equipped with more than one charge they
are a special case of topological spaces
yes they are topological manifolds or
are also every topological manifold is a
topological space but not every
topological space is a topological
manifold so yes a topological manifold
is a special case of a topological space
topological space are the minimal
structure required to define continuity
of maps no this is not correct
continuity of maps can already be
checked on topological spaces and the
last question of the last answer says
that topological manifolds are
homeomorphic to our Dean now we have
just to define what a homeomorphisms
a homeomorphism that's better same two
spaces m and n are called homeomorphic
if there is a protection X from M to n
where the map X as well as its inverse
are both continuous so in the case of a
topological manifold there are such
homomorphisms homeomorphisms sorry
between the topological space underlying
and Rd however the answer says that a
topological manifold is homeomorphic to
the whole of Rd well that is not correct
we have that that a the part of a
topological my thought namely an open
subset is homeomorphic to some part of
Rd so this is not correct as a
topological manifold is usually not
homeomorphic to hole of Rd however we
could say a topological manifold is
locally homeomorphic to Rd in Part B it
says which statements about topological
manifolds are correct any trouble
logical manifold has a maximal atlas yes
it does so a topological manifold comes
equipped with some atlas and there's a
unique and there's a theorem that says
you can uniquely build from any atlas in
maximal atlas so this answer is correct
a maximal atlas on a topological
manifold may contain infinitely many
charts yes of course it may contain
infinitely many continuity of a curve on
a topological manifold
we checked with respect to an atlas oh
yes it can be checked we saw this in the
lecture an atlas of a topological
manifold can never contain only one
chart but this statement is nonsense of
course it can contain only one shot and
we will see an example for that later on
and the last part in the last question
if a function is continuous in one shot
it is continuous in every chart of a
maximal atlas of a topological manifold
although this question is a little bit
ambiguous this is correct so we look at
a function that's continuous in one shot
and then we look at another chart that
has overlap with the original chart and
there we know that due to the
composition of continuous maps being
continuous the function is also
continuous in this other chart and then
we can look at even more overlaps with
more charts and we see that the function
is continuous and all charts of a
maximum atlas but we need to restrict
ourselves to charts and overlap each
other and the last question here see it
is correct that the real line are
equipped with a standard topology and an
atlas whose only chart is the identity
map over the topological space R is a
topological manifold of dimension 1 this
is correct so this is an example for a
for an atlas of a topological manifold
that contains exactly one chart
a topological manifold can have a finite
set underlying no this is wrong we saw
that the topological manifold is locally
homeomorphic to Rd so it looks like it
locally looks like some part of our D
however Rd and all its subsets are
uncountably however a finite set cannot
look like something uncountably so this
is wrong a topological manifold can
never have a topology that is a subset
apology well this is pure nonsense we
saw many examples in the lecture where
there was a subset apology and on a
topological manifold the topological
space s 42 which is the 42 42
dimensional sphere we cannot build an
atlas for it well of course we can so
there is no reason why we shouldn't be
able to do so so wrong and the last
answer a function from some m2r
can only be said to be continuous if M
is a topological manifold well that is
also not correct
since continuity or can already be
checked on a topological space we don't
need the notion of a topological
manifold therefore so this was the first
exercise some questions about
topological many faults and now we go to
the second exercise we look at the
Mobius River
and one we want look at the movie a
strip you can see it here which has a
river printed on
and from this mobius strip which is our
manifold we want to build an atlas so
let's look at the mobius strip so a
mobius strip can be decomposed on paper
in this way that means we identify this
edge running from top to bottom here
this way with the other edge but here
the other way around from bottom to the
top that's how we can construct a movie
a strip and now we have a river flowing
on it so imagine this is just some river
and now let's look at charts for this
mobius strip
so we need we cannot cover the Mobius
strip with one chart we need to so we
can choose this here which has this
domain we call this the domain u1 and we
have another chart here that has this
domain we call it YouTube and you can
see you have overlap here as well as
here and now how does this movie a strip
look like in the chart so for domain u 1
we find some chart X that maps u 1 to R
2 or some part of our two actually so
this is some part of r2 and the Mobius
strip with the Mabius River printed on
it looks for example like this
and the other chart which has domain you
- we call it Y also maps to some part
are too so and in the chart the Mobius
River looks for example like this so we
constructed two charts for the Mobius
strip in the collection of this charge
together with this chart and forms and
atlas for the Mobius strip equipped with
the mughals River in the next exercise
exercise 3 we will consider the other
way round
we now are given an atlas and we want to
form the corresponding manifold so we
have four charts that I've also got here
now we need to find the overlaps in
these charts you can for example see see
that here we got overlap and also we can
add this chart here and the forth chart
can be put here so now we have found the
overlaps of these four charts and what
do we see
we can overlap down here and up here as
well as overlap here in the left but
here on the right so what we have
is a map that is identified here so this
edge identified with this edge in the
same orientation as well as here bottom
and top are identified in the same
direction and what we get is a Taurus
the g2 so what we got for our manifold
is a Taurus equipped with some charts we
have now build a manifold from an atlas
as well as an atlas from a manifold and
in the last exercise which is
you
called for the invention of the wheel we
look at an another example of a
topological manifold so let's consider
the set F 1 that is consists of the
pairs of real numbers m and n let
satisfy the condition M to the power 4
plus n to the power of 4 is equal to 1
it is equipped with a subset apology
inherited from the standard topology on
r2 so we look at a map F 1 to R that
Maps a pair in f1 to its first entry you
should write this down in formal
mathematical terms so we have the map X
that maps from f1 but not into the real
numbers as a whole but only in two
subsets minus 1 to 1 with minus 1 and 1
included and it takes such a pair M an N
and maps it to its first entry which is
M so is this map injective well it isn't
so let's look at the image of the pair 0
1 under X well we map it to the first
entry that is 0 and if we now look at
the image of the pair 0 minus 1 it also
gets mapped to 0 so with this map we hit
the 0 in the target twice this violates
injectivity
first X is not injective
however this map X can be made injective
if we restrict its domain to either of
two maximal open subsets of f1 okay
let's do this so we called this
restricted map now X arrow up and the
restriction now is the set of all these
pairs m and n are to that of course
still fulfill the condition that m to
the power of 4 plus n to the power of 4
is equal to 1 but now restrict ourselves
to pairs whose second entry is larger
than 0 by excluding the equal sign we
ensure that this that the resulting
domain is such an open set as required
in the question and of course still we
map to the interval minus 1 to 1 however
this is now the open interval as the
borders are excluded and such pairs m
and n are still mapped to a first entry
M the second map X arrow down as we call
it is constructed accordingly we take
again pairs MN from our to fulfilling
our condition m to power 4 plus n to
power 4 is 1 and n is now smaller than 0
the targets again the open set from
minus 1 to 1 and the
here still gets mapped to the first
entry M and now we see this map here is
clearly injective now we can construct
an injective map Y arrow up from F 1 to
R that map's every pair in a maximal
open subset of F 1 to the second entry
of the pair
so let's construct it Y arrow up I have
to restrict our domain to a subset of F
1 for y arrow up to be injective so we
can pick m and n the pair in R 2 with
our usual condition from F 1 and now we
say we have first entry M larger than 0
and we still map in the target minus 1
to 1 and now we take such a pair M and N
and map it to the first entry sorry of
course so the second entry n this map is
injective and now we can work with it is
it invertible well yes it is so we see
in the most injective as well as we can
easily check that is surjective which
means then y arrow up is by objective
and the inverse y arrow up inverse
exists
how can we construct this inverse that's
not particularly difficult so now the
domain of the inverse was is the target
of the map of the old map
so the real interval from minus 1 to 1
which is open gets mapped from the old
domain which is now the target yet mn in
our to fulfilling the usual condition
and we have that M is larger than 0 so
we take some real number a in the
interval minus 1 to 1 and it gets mapped
to a in the second entry and for the
condition M to the power 4 plus n to the
power of 4 is equal to 1 for this to
hold we need here the 4th root of 1
minus a to the power of 4 this is the
inverse map why arrow op inverse and now
we look at a possible overlap of the
domains of the map X arrow up and Y
arrow up
well there is overlap and it is the set
M n in r2 but of course fulfill our
usual condition and power 4 plus n to
the power 4 is 1 but now we have that M
is larger than 0 as well as n is larger
than 0
and now we are asked to construct the
transition map X arrow up after y arrow
up of course we can only construct this
transition map on the overlap of X arrow
up and Y arrow up and if we now remember
where X arrow up and white arrow up map
in this it's just the main we see that
the domain of the transition map is the
real interval from 0 to 1 and we map it
to the interval 0 to 1 all intervals are
open here and we take some number as
real number s from this interval and it
first gets mapped to X arrow up off
white arrow up inverse of s so this is X
arrow up of the pair the 4th root of 1
minus s to the power of 4 and s here we
constructed this explicitly in the in
the question before and X arrow up
projected out the first entry of this
pair and this is the 4th root 1 of 1
minus s to the power of 4 we see that
this is clearly a number in the interval
0 to 1 and thus we have constructed the
transition map X Arad after wire-wrapped
inverse and the last question is how
many maps constructed this way do you
need for the domains to cover the whole
that f1 well we saw that the domain of
white arrow up of X arrow and X arrow
down they covered f1 without the pairs 1
0 and minus 1 0 Y arrow up and we can
analogously construct white arrow down
they cover f1 without the points 0 1 and
0 minus 1 so we need four Maps X arrow
up X arrow down white arrow up and y
arrow down to cover f1 and of course the
collection of the domains of these 4
maps and the Maps itself form an atlas
on f1 and
thus we have seen we have constructed an
atlas for our set f1 and we could and we
can see that f1 is a topological
manifold of dimension 1